davey yeah let's be impulsive let's not
get into depth where we're talking about
enlightenment elevate actualize just
think of a number between 100. mm-hmm
you got it mm-hmm and here i'm gonna i'm
gonna sneak over here just i'm gonna get
rich i wanna see this jason how long
have you known davey um
less than a year actually but he was
about to stay too long that was kind of
offensive uh no i'm kidding yeah
okay done
bam
and tell me your name blake blake
okay
i'm only gonna ask one question i'm
gonna show you
does the number have some sort of
significance or just kind of pop in your
head just pop them off no good okay so
here hear me out when people do
significant numbers there's like a
reason didn't feel i'm not gonna need a
birthday but then he seemed excited
probably higher
what would davey do
free spirit probably an odd number all
right go with this grab the pen i wrote
21 i wrote 21 i crossed it out was it 21
i'd be super pissed blake you think it
was higher too what did you go with tell
me tell blake tell rich tell us all what
do you think what's that number 65. did
i tell you higher tell them what i wrote
you saw tell me i wrote i crossed out 21
and wrote down 65. i knew he'd go odd
what the hell
too far out you can stay in frame do you
not want to be in no that's just fine
think of someone you're going to talk to
and i'm guessing i'm hoping i told you
my whole job is to be memorable that
you're going to be like oh my god we
have this guy always on rich and it was
just crazy and you're going to tell
someone about this
so it could be a family member
it could be a friend it could be
somebody random this could be more
random like something you're just going
to have a conversation with
go through your mind and think of
someone you
are very likely to talk to the next
couple weeks okay you got someone yeah i
got someone is it an obvious choice
uh
no i don't think so okay want to go with
it rich hold on to this for me would any
of them know this person uh yeah okay
but not an obvious choice if i ask
everyone to guess right now do you think
they would know oh no they wouldn't know
they wouldn't know just jot down the
person's first name
show them
okay very important rich got my wallet
make sure doesn't steal all my cash next
make sure i can't see anything from over
here
hold on it didn't focus
okay got it
all right can i come back yeah
fold it again
okay fold it again just so it doesn't
pop right open whatever okay okay
you guys saw it mm-hmm
i'm totally kidding he would have done
it this guy's intense all right next
best thing destroy look rip shred hard
eye contact riff make sure i'm gonna
pull out your hand okay he could have
thought of a guy or a girl are we in
agreement are there any scraps left over
no
now you could guess this because once
you see it you can kind of tell
could have picked a guy or a girl but i
said to him is it somebody obvious and
then he kind of reacted and then next
look at the body language super relaxed
still it's a guy am i right yeah of
course there's a woman be a little more
excited right now i'm gonna touch that
beard too always always the beard touch
classic thinking of her you're going gq
are you going to see him
which indicates either he lives close by
or something like that you guys have
plans because when i said you're going
to probably talk to the person or likely
just going to be like a text like what's
the what's the vibe on this do you think
you'll see the person yeah i'll go for
like open the wall please open the wall
yeah
we never met we've never spoken did i
did you did is there a way that could
have known he'd be here during this
if there's a photo of this guy in there
you're going to flip out
yeah
he's about to get a restraining order
okay no kidding let's get this davey
jason you do it last time you got to
help the zipper come on over come on
close open up the little zipper please
and my business card
says my name my number but i wrote some
on the back of blake read it to him
say hello to even for me oh my god what
that's not even a common name i know
that's the thing i like there's no way
he's gonna guess his name
that's not true
if he can sense what you're sensing
now here's what i mean sense like right
now if i squeeze your shoulder uh-huh
he's gonna say he felt someone squeeze
his shoulder over there he's gonna be
like somebody's squeezing my shoulder i
swear let's say i brushed your cheek
did you feel anything on your cheek
no do you know why because i'm not
insane right why would that happen it's
not like what but
i need an actual connection you can't do
wireless let me move you over do this
hold out your finger and your finger
like et phone home come a little closer
lock it in come on closer i want to be
close while this is happening all right
davey look at me
close your eyes
can everybody
see davey
clearly right but davey can't see us so
you can't say that he's pretending or
that he's going like i think i felt that
or whatever davey have you felt anything
yet no
did you just feel me
tap your forearm yeah all right he's
sober that was me he was like freaked
out he's like oh my god it's amazing his
eyes are closed daily the part of this i
want you to remember is your eyes are
closed and i want to ask you a question
tell us all right now what did i do to
you what did you feel just now no like
when i when i had a few seconds ago i
just asked you yeah what did you feel
tap my phone on no after that i smelled
something on my lip or below my nose
it was after right it was a few seconds
after the arm did it feel like i kind of
brushed down your nose and ate your lip
yeah okay hold on
it didn't feel quite uh
have you felt anything since then no
let's timestamp it because he said when
i just want to make sure how about right
now did you feel anything
[Music]
uh davey don't open your eyes
my theory here oh i don't want you guys
to miss it is it the moment i do
something to rich it travels it goes
through your hand all the way over
notice how his lips kind of quivered a
little bit do me a favor wake up open
your eyes open your eyes
what did you just feel my chin
i took this before i brushed down his
nose and i just brushed his chin right
before you opened your eyes
i don't know why they're still touching
fingers by the way
it's getting weird
[Music]
you